[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg
sprachen von einem logistikrennen die
Ukraine brauchen Munition und Treibstoff
und zwar schnell an den Fronten im Osten
des Landes ist der Munitionsmangel für
die ukrainische Armee das aktuell
drängendste Problem es geht darum den
russischen Attacken Stand zu halten die
dort kämpfen wie anno dazu mal im Ersten
Weltkrieg mit Artillerie und Massen an
Soldaten die regelrecht verheizt werden
ein brutales Gemetzel das von Tag zu Tag
härter wird indem sie aber auch die
Russen aufreiben und mittendrin leben
immer noch Zivilisten und Ulrike
berichten
die Helfer vom Roten Kreuz sind
angekommen hier in slofiansk im Osten
der Ukraine wo die Kämpfe von Tag zu Tag
brutaler werden sie bringen die Alten
und Kranken in Sicherheit für sie ist
dieses Krankenhaus kein guter Ort mehr
auch wenn viele von ihnen gar nicht weg
wollen es bricht ihnen das Herz
wir werden nicht lange weg sein und dort
wo wir hinfahren wird es sicher sein
später könnt ihr wieder zurück alles ist
okay weine nicht
in der Ostukraine vergeht kein Tag ohne
russische Raketenangriffe und
Artilleriebeschuss so wie hier in der
seit Wochen schwer umkämpften Stadt
bachmut
etwa 5000 Menschen sind noch in der
Stadt geblieben vor dem Krieg waren es
etwa 70.000 der freie journalistamt
Ginzel weinbachmut und hat diese Bilder
gedreht er hat Menschen getroffen die
trotz der schweren Kämpfe bleiben
wohin sollen wir fahren wer braucht uns
dort auf uns wartet niemand
hier ist mein Zuhause hier ist mein Sohn
begraben
seit Wochen versucht die russische Armee
bachmut zu erobern das sollen diese
Bilder aus dem russischen Fernsehen
zeigen mit schweren eigenen Verlusten
sagen britische Militärexperten die
ukrainische Armee hält der russischen
Offensive stand noch
am Ziel hat die Stadt nicht eingenommen
noch immer wird
gibt es hier schwere Kämpfe zwischen
ukrainischen und russischen
Streitkräften die sich recht nah kommen
zwischen Abschuss und Einschlag Vergehen
oftmals nur wenige Sekunden nicht weit
von Kiew entfernt trägt rosa maximenko
ihren Mann zu Grabe er wurde bei den
Kämpfen in bachmut getötet alexandra hat
sich als Freiwilliger bei der
ukrainischen Armee gemeldet nun hat sie
ihn nach Hause geholt
[Musik]
ein abnutzungskrieg bei dem Putin auf
Zeit setzt darauf dass der Ukraine
Munition und Menschen ausgehen und
darauf dass die Unterstützung des
Westens irgendwann bröckelt das
Amerikaner und Europäer sagen das muss
jetzt ein Ende haben und die Ukraine zu
Kompromissen bringen die für Putin einen
Gewinn wären wie weit die Bereitschaft
der unterstützerländer geht ist
jedenfalls bei weitem nicht so klar wie
es oft behauptet wird spätestens bei den
bereit diskutierten kampfpanzerthema
zeigt sich das fordern leichter fällt
als liefern das wurde auch beim Treffen
der NATO Verteidigungsminister heute in
Brüssel wieder sehr deutlich die Florian
neu haben beobachtet hat
bitte schauen sie für 8 Sekunden in die
Kameras es geht heute um Ziele um
Zusagen bei der NATO und das ist wohl
die die sie am leichtesten Einheiten
können acht Sekunden Lächeln und ab
denke wenn man doch dann wird es schon
schwieriger etwa bei Kampfpanzern für
die Ukraine Ende Januar hatte die
deutsche Regierung ein Ziel ausgegeben
dem Land ein ganzes Bataillon zu liefern
gut 30 Leopard Kampfpanzer Typ 26 heute
in Brüssel muss der
Verteidigungsminister ernüchtert
festhalten auf der Seite der 216 sind es
14 deutsche A6 und 3 portugiesische
werden wir nicht ganz der werden wir die
bataillonstärke nicht erreichen einfach
auch deshalb nicht weil es nicht so
viele Sechser gibt Zusage vervielt auch
weil andere Länder ihre Panzer behalten
wollen um im Zweifel eigenes Gebiet
verteidigen zu können was zur Zusage
führt Geld fürs eigene Militär
2014 auf dem Gipfel in Wales hatten sich
die NATO-Staaten ein Versprechen gegeben
ihre Verteidigungsausgaben auf den
Richtwert von 2% des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts zuzubewegen bald
braucht die NATO ein neues Ziel und
Boris Pistorius legt sich heute fest
ich glaube nicht allein dem 2% Ziel
annähernd zu wollen wird nicht reichen
es kann muss die Basis sein für alles
weitere und dann gibt es noch die großen
Fragen an die sich eher ehemalige trauen
welche Garantien für die Zukunft kann
die NATO der Ukraine geben
Ex-Generalsekretär anders vor grasmussen
schlägt einen sicherheitspakt vor in dem
mächtige Staaten von den USA bis
Deutschland langfristig militärische
Hilfe garantieren wir haben time
Betrieben heute und eine möglichen NATO
Beitritt wird die Ukraine
Sicherheitsgarantien brauchen und hier
wäre so ein sicherheitspakt eine Brücke
das hatten sie schon mal 94 gab die
Ukraine ihre Atomwaffen ab gegen eine
Garantie von Russland die Souveränität
des Landes zu achten sie war das Papier
nicht wert heute bräuchte es mehr
Sicherheitsgarantien müssen immer
einhergehen mit einer massiven
Aufrüstung der ukrainischen Streitkräfte
so dass es zwei Sachen abschreckend
wirken also einmal sozusagen die
militärische Potenz der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte und das zweite die dahinter
stehenden Staaten es ist nur eine Idee
noch längst keine Zusage damit sind sie
heute erst einmal vorsichtig
fangen wir noch nach bei Florian neuhahn
in Brüssel täuschte Eindruck oder dritte
deutsche Verteidigungsminister der
neuerdings als Antreiber auf
erstmal musste er heute eine Niederlage
verkünden nämlich dass eben Deutschland
dieses angekündigte Ziel bei der
kampfpanzerkoalition deutlich verfehlt
aber das kann man fairerweise an den
Minister nicht angreifen der gerade mal
selbst vier Wochen im Amt ist und auch
nach meinem Eindruck versuchte er das
heute wegzumachen durch einen kräftiges
auftreten was ich vor allem in diesem
Vorstoß widerspiegelte dieses berühmte
und umstrittene zwei Prozent Ziel der
NATO bei den Verteidigungsausgaben noch
einmal zu verschärfen das wäre nicht
weniger als eine deutliche Kehrtwende
des bisherigen Kurses der deutschen
Regierung die dieses Ziel immer
skeptisch sah und auch hier in Brüssel
bei der NATO immer argumentierte man
müsste doch mehr auf die Fähigkeiten
achten und weniger auf diese eine fixe
Prozentzahl und es setzt natürlich auch
andere Länder unter Druck die bei dieser
Verschärfung nicht ganz so euphorisch
mitgehen wollen
dieser dieser Vorstoß die
Verteidigungshaushalte auf mindestens
mindestens zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts anzuheben ist da
eigentlich mit der Ampelkoalition
abgesprochen geht da in in jeder mit
das habe ich ein Pistorius heute hier in
Brüssel auch gefragt und er sagte
daraufhin dass er abgesprochen mit dem
Bundeskanzler also Olaf Scholz und mit
dem spd-parteivorsitzenden also Lars
Klingbeil aber im Umkehrschluss ist auch
klar wer damit nicht gemeint ist wer
also nicht mitgehen würde bisher nämlich
der Mann der sich in der Regierung um
die Finanzen kümmert FDP Finanzminister
Christian Lindner man muss wohl kein
Hellseher sein um zu sagen das ist
darüber in den nächsten Wochen in der
Koalition noch heftig Knirschen wird
denn man müsste in den nächsten Jahren
um dieses Ziel selbst zu erfüllen auch
ziemlich viel Geld einige Milliarden in
das eigene Militär stecken und das hieße
entweder neue Schulden aufzunehmen was
einem FDP Finanzminister nicht gefallen
dürfte oder eben anders wozu kürzen und
dann wäre eben die große Frage wo hmm
danke schön Florian nach Brüssel
das dürfte noch erhebliche Diskussionen
darum gehen bald ein Jahr geht dieser
Krieg schon der die Welt verändert hat
und das Leben so vieler Menschen und bis
dahin eher weniger beachteter Präsident
wurde zu einer überlebensgroßen Figur
der Zeitgeschichte seine Bevölkerung
kämpft um ihr Überleben und die Existenz
ihres Staates aber auch für die anderen
Europäer für uns in Deutschland gab es
eine abrupte zeitenwände in einer Serie
fürs heute journal begegnet Christian
Sievers verschiedenen Menschen die für
diese zeitenwände stehen deren Leben
oder Arbeit plötzlich auf den Kopf
gestellt wurde er beginnt mit Robert
Habeck der ja eigentlich als Klimawende
Minister angetreten war und sie
stattdessen rund um die Uhr mit
gaseinkäufen Kohlekraftwerken und
lng-terminals befassen muss
es hat wieder länger gedauert jetzt ist
der Zeitplan in Gefahr
wer Robert Habeck folgt muss gut zu Fuß
sein
er selbst liebt solche Bilder ein
Minister der sich keine Pause leisten
kann Gaskrise Energie-
ich muss sagen ganz schön durchbrechen
wartet aber im Ministerium schon der
nächste Termin und auf den bereite ich
mich hier so schnell vor Kantine
Mittagessen gibt's bei ihm nie sagen die
Mitarbeiter manchmal schläft er schlecht
sagt er selbst aber der permanente
Ausnahmezustand im Ministerium sei jetzt
vorbei das macht das einfacher also das
Leute planbare pausezeiten haben und
nicht in ewigen langen
Telefonkonferenzen mit mir oder
untereinander ihre Wochenenden
gescheitert haben ein Alarm im Jahr das
vieles geschreddert hat
beinahe auch seinen Ruf weil die Frage
aufkam ist Harbeck all dem gewachsen
mittlerweile wirkt er entspannt wenn man
mit ihm spricht schönes Büro schönes
Büro finde ich ist das für sie ein
Vorteil oder Nachteil so im Rampenlicht
zu stehen wie kein Wirtschaftsminister
vor ihnen das also als ich hier
reingekommen bin von Ludwig Erhard da
ich glaube der Stadt mehr haben Licht
sicher nö als wenn man bedenkt aber
Energie Klima und Wirtschaft
gleichzeitig in dieser Zeit also ich
denke da nicht drüber nach das ist die
öffentliche Beobachtung und Erklärung
dessen was wir tun ist Teil des Jobs das
ist wieder was worüber ich klage noch
etwas was
[Musik]
einem irgendwie besondere Freude
bereitet oder stolz macht und das ist
einfach Teil des Jobs und es gibt
einfach viel zu erklären viel erklären
das ist Stil und Strategie zugleich zwei
Mitarbeiterinnen mit Smartphone immer im
Schlepptau das Social Media Team des
Ministeriums im Grunde sagt Habeck sei
er der oberste Presse im Haus das
Ministerium einen schier endloses
Labyrinth von Gängen für das sie hier
Lagepläne ausgeben in dem eine
Energiekrise zu managen war und auch
Fehler gemacht wurden wenn ich das
aussprechen soll es gab keine
Alternative es gab keine 30 Milliarden
umgebaut zu retten es war der einzige
Weg den Markt Chemie zu halten auch die
für das Vertrauen der Investoren dazu
hat insofern war das auch wenn wir
später geändert haben in dem Moment
richtig dieser jetzt Umlage geändert sie
haben sehr zurück genommen
mit der Gasanlage und dann zu sagen
jetzt gehe ich wieder voll raus
wenn ich aus Angst vor Fehler nicht mehr
entscheiden würde keine Angst vor
Fehlern sagt der häufig aber natürlich
weiß er zu viele Fehler kann sich
niemand leisten in Brunsbüttel ist
Harbeck als Energieminister unterwegs
eröffnet ein weiteres schwimmendes
gasterminal dass der Winter in
Deutschland nicht dunkel und kalt wurde
nimmt er als Bestätigung seiner Arbeit
der klimaschutzminister Habeck hat es
schwer die Ladung hier kommt aus Abu
Dhabi ein langfristiger Großauftrag für
die Industrie auch die RWE Manager
Lächeln hier in die Kameras und ein
CDU-Mann lobt Habeck über den grünen
Klee er hatte auch bestimmte Ideologien
zur Seite geräumt um eben auch solche
Projekte die hier zu ermöglichen aber
weiträumig abgesperrt vor den Toren
rufen Sie Verrat
das ist ein klimaverbrechen also ich
glaube die grüne Politik hat hier
versagt ganz ehrlich
Habeck Habeck du warst mal okay doch
dann kam RWE singen sie in der
klima-bewegung für den Grünen Minister
dürfte das die größte Herausforderung
werden wenn nicht ein massives Problem
aber nochmal zurück zu dem Song du warst
mal okay da spricht ja durchaus
Bewunderung raus aber gleichzeitig auch
tiefe Enttäuschung jetzt das muss ihnen
doch was was mit ihnen macht aber das
ich will da keine härter reinbringen ich
habe ja schon gesagt dass man die
jeweiligen Rollen verstehen muss und
auch akzeptieren muss aber wenn es an
den Enttäuschung gibt dann liegt die in
weiten Teilen Informiertheit nach einem
Jahr Krisenmanagement muss er nicht nur
seiner Partei zeigen wie er die
Klimaziele einhalten will Robert Habeck
wird jetzt daran gemessen ob er die
deutsche Energiewende schafft
und jetzt geht es bei Heinz Wolf weiter
mit anderen Nachrichten des Tages die
Bundesregierung will mit einer
gesetzlichen Änderung erreichen dass
schneller gegen Verfassungsfeinde im
öffentlichen Dienst vorgegangen werden
kann der vom Kabinett beschloss eine
Entwurf sieht unter anderem vor dass der
jeweilige diensther künftig direkt eine
Disziplinarverfügung wie eine
Zurückstufung aussprechen kann
gleichzeitig sollen die Hürden für eine
Entfernung aus dem Beamtenverhältnis
nach einer strafrechtlichen Verurteilung
gesenkt werden
das in Halle geplante zukunftszentrum
für deutsche Einheit und europäische
Transformation ist aus Sicht von
sachsen-anhaltsministerpräsident
Haseloff ein länderübergreifendes
Projekt daraus müsse ein gesamtdeutscher
Erfolg werden sagte Haseloff in Berlin
ziel ist ein Ort an dem Leistungen der
Menschen aus und in Ostdeutschland
sichtbar gemacht werden und einen
öffentlichen Raum für Dialog zu schaffen
der Bund investiert 200 Millionen Euro
in den Bau und jährlich weitere 40
Millionen Euro in den Betrieb 2028 soll
es eröffnet werden
die bei der Wahl zum Berliner
Abgeordnetenhaus zunächst
liegengebliebenen Wahlbriefe sind
ausgezählt es ging um 466 Umschläge von
Briefwählern im Bezirk Lichtenberg und
damit auch um die Plätze 2 und 3 hinter
der Wahlsiegerin CDU der knappe
Vorsprung der SPD vor den Grünen hat
sich nach Medienberichten noch leicht
vergrößert offiziell wird das Resultat
kommende Woche bekannt gegeben
die EU-Kommission reicht im Streit mit
Polen über die Prinzipien von
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Klage beim
Gerichtshof der Europäischen Union ein
Auslöser sind Urteile des polnischen
Verfassungsgerichts mit denen Vorgaben
von EU-Verträgen als verfassungswidrig
eingestuft und der Vorrang von EU-Recht
von nationalem Recht in Frage gestellt
wurden die EU-Kommission sieht darin
einen Verstoß gegen allgemeine
Grundsätze wie die einheitliche
Anwendung von Unionsrecht
Schottlands Regierungschefin stirgin hat
überraschend ihren Rücktritt angekündigt
auch als Chefin der schottischen
Nationalpartei wegen zu großer
Belastungen wie sie erklärte zuletzt
waren sie vor allem im Zusammenhang mit
den Unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen und
wegen einer Debatte über die Rechte von
Transgendern in die Kritik geraten ist
ihre Nachfolge geklärtheit bleiben Sie
immer Amt
in den Katastrophengebieten in der
Türkei und Syrien bricht jetzt eine
besonders furchtbare Zeit aus bisher
konnte man immer noch jeden Tag Hoffnung
haben jeder Mensch der lebend aus den
Trümmern herausgezogen wurde wurde
bejubelt und gab Rettern und Anwohnern
psychische Kraft jetzt gibt es diese
Momente der Hoffnung nur noch sehr
selten wenn jetzt noch Überlebende
gefunden werden grenzt das an ein Wunder
und die Menschen wissen dass es diese
wunderbar bald gar nicht mehr geben wird
bitte Jäger berichtet aus dem türkischen
Antakya
sie passen ganz genau auf an welcher
Stelle die Bagger der Suchtrupps gerade
den Schutz zur Seite räumen und bitten
immer wieder bloß vorsichtig zu sein die
Hoffnung ihre Angehörigen noch Leben zu
finden haben die meisten längst
aufgegeben aber die Toten soll der
Bagger wenigstens nicht zermeiden
andere dagegen sitzen nur da und sind
ganz still wenn es soweit ist wollen sie
ihre Toten identifizieren geschieht das
nicht sofort werden die als namenlose in
ein Massengrab am Stadtrand
transportiert wenigstens eine würdevolle
Beerdigung dieser Moment des Leids steht
so her noch bevor warten auf die tote
Familie
das ist eine so schlimme Situation wenn
du deine Lieben verlierst wenn Sie meine
rausholen werde ich sie zurück nach
Syrien bringen zurück in die alte Heimat
am südlichsten Zipfel der Türkei einst
so reich an Geschichte so bunt und
multireligiös ist jetzt nur noch grau
und voller Staub ein Trümmerhaufen mit
am stärksten hat es auch eine der
Hauptstraßen Richtung Altstadt getroffen
hier waren die Häuser schon vor dem
Beben alt und marode bewohnt vor allem
von der großen syrischen Community
eigentlich teilte Ali beyazid mit seiner
Hilfsorganisation Decken und Nahrung aus
jetzt hilft er mit nach Leichen zu
suchen das letzte große Erdbeben vor
März 20 Jahren hat ihn abgehärtet ich
habe öfters alles mögliche gesehen was
ein Mensch was ein wirklich nicht sehen
will aber jetzt ist für uns sagen
leicht wer ein Ticket nach draußen hat
für den gibt es eine bessere Option als
die Zelte der Hammer Social Club
organisiert Busse für alle die bei
Freunden und Verwandten anderswo im Land
unterkommen können kurz nachdem Beben
waren es hier tausende die Amar Ana so
aus der Stadt gebracht hat nach dem
Beben nach diesem Desaster waren alle so
geschockt die Leute sind einfach so wie
sie waren hergekommen manche Frauen die
normalerweise immer Kopftuch getragen
haben kam plötzlich ohne und viele
Kinder ohne Schuhe jetzt Tage später
arbeiten die Bagger schneller die
schwarzen Säcke die für so viel Leid
stehen werden jetzt fast in Minutentakt
gebraucht und zwar an allen Ecken
attackier ist am Boden buchstäblich
wenn sie spenden wollen das
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe hat
folgendes Konto
de65-100-400 600-100 400 600 Stichwort
ZDF Erdbeben Türkei Syrien informationen
auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf
Seite 890
was vielen Akteuren auf dieser Welt die
Demokratie als Staatsform ein Dorn im
Auge ist wissen wir aber wie weit das
geht Demokratien zu bekämpfen ist in
seinem vollen Umfang wahrscheinlich noch
nicht jedem bewusst es hat ja zum
Beispiel auch länger gedauert bis man
begriff was ist mit Putins sogenannten
toll Fabriken auf sich hat die auf
Stimmungsmache abzielen oder wie
versucht wird Wahlen zu beeinflussen und
das ist regelrechte
it-agenturen gibt die verdeckt
politische Kampagnen
einen internationales
journalistennetzwerk hat nun
recherchiert wie eine geheime agierende
Truppe mit Sitz in Israel arbeitet an
den monatelangen Recherchen waren
Journalisten aus mehr als 30 Redaktionen
beteiligt unter anderem von der
israelischen Tageszeitung harrets Radio
Fonds und dem Guardian in Deutschland
recherchierte das ZDF gemeinsam mit dem
Spiegel und der Zeit
Armin Körper und Felix klausergerich
Proteste Aufstände
Wahlen was davon ist authentisch was
manipuliert
auf der Suche nach denen die
Desinformation betreiben gehen drei
Journalisten undercover nach
monatelanger Recherche gelingt es ihnen
sich einzuschleusen in eine Gruppe die
sich Team Kochen nennt die von sich
selbst sagt dass sie in Afrika Asien und
Europawahlen manipulieren kann aber
offiziell gar nicht existiert
habt ihr gesehen was an der Tür steht
nichts kein Klingelschild kein Name wir
sind nichts wir sind Luft
das ist das erste Mal dass die Welt so
eine Fabrik für Fake News und
Manipulation der Demokratie von innen
sieht das ist anders als alles was wir
zuvor gesehen haben
die Kernkompetenz der kriminellen Handys
hacken und künstliche Identitäten
Avatare in sozialen Medien erstellen mit
Ihnen Fake News verbreiten
über 30.000 von ihnen wollen die Männer
steuern die Journalisten sind live dabei
sehen wie Team Horrer ein gefälschtes
Profil erstellt
die haben uns gezeigt wie sie Avatare
kreieren so wie ich mir eine Pizza
zusammenstelle
die Avatare haben sogar bitcoin-konten
diverse Accounts im Netz so werden Fake
News Kampagnen glaubwürdiger
Wahlbetrug und Korruption als
Dienstleistung
das Geschäft von Team hoche für Geld
Wahlen torpedieren
wir sind aktuell mit einer Wahl in
Afrika beschäftigt haben aber auch ein
Team in Griechenland
Kenia im August 2022 nach der Wahl kommt
es zu Unruhen
Manipulationsvorwürfe werden laut
dem ZDF liegen Hinweise vor das Team
hoche hier im Einsatz war
nach Monaten gelingt es die Männer zu
identifizieren Roche heißt in Wahrheit
talhanann nach eigenen Angaben ein
ex-elite-soldat Israels mit den
Vorwürfen konfrontiert teilt er mit um
es klar zu sagen ich weise zurück dass
ich etwas Falsches getan habe die
Enthüllung ist Teil des Projekts Story
Killers des investigativen Netzwerks vor
bitten Stories dass die gravierenden
Folgen von
Desinformationskampagnen aufzeigen will
ich werde es dir sagen es geht nicht um
eine freie Entscheidung es geht nur um
einen Krieg der gewonnen werden muss
es ist ein neuer Einblick in den Kampf
gegen die Demokratie vielleicht zum
ersten Mal von innen
jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal weiter
Heinz ein Topthema heute der Flugbetrieb
in Deutschland zum einen wegen des
Warnstreik Aufrufs von Verdi für Freitag
und zum anderen wegen der Störung heute
Stefanie Barrett hat sich die Lage
inzwischen wieder normalisiert also es
wird wohl noch morgen werden bis am
größten deutschen Luftfahrt Rekord hier
in Frankfurt wirklich alles wieder
reibungslos läuft immerhin werden aber
Flugzeuge wieder abgefertigt und der
Flugbetrieb normalisiert sich eine
Bauplane unter der Erde hatte seit dem
frühen Morgen für erhebliche Störungen
im weltweiten Luftverkehr gesorgt aber
er war ein Telekom Glasfaserkabel in
fünf Metern Tiefe von einem Betonbohrer
durchtrennt worden nicht nur viele
Haushalte waren danach ohne Internet und
Telefon sondern auch weiter Teile der
lufthansaiti außer Gefecht gesetzt fast
nichts ging mehr weil die Systeme fürs
einchecken und Boden streiten bis zum
frühen Abend vielen allein am Drehkreuz
Frankfurt über 240 Flüge aus hunderte
Passagiere warteten auf ihre Umbuchung
und eine weitere Belastungsprobe droht
Flugreisenden bereits am Freitag der
legt die Gewerkschaft Verdi mit einem
ganztägigen Warnstreik den Flugbetrieb
gleich an sieben deutschen Airports
weitgehend lahm und durch Kreuz damit
die Reisepläne von rund 300.000
Passagieren immerhin einen Trost hat die
Lufthansa parat inlandsreisende dürfen
noch bis Sonntag mit ihrem Flugticket
auf die Bahn ausweichen
vielen Dank
und bevor wir gleich noch zum Sport
kommen die Zahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch
sie lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr 19 22
26 33 37 45 und die Superzahl 6 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de
und im zdf-
bei der Ski-WM im französischen marybell
gab es heute überraschend Gold für einen
dsv-rennläufer Alexander Schmied gewann
im parallelwettbewerb
Lido Strasser heute früh ausgeschieden
in den Armen des Goldschmieds der eine
Zentner Last von allen die ESV Athleten
nimmt
souverän gewinnt der 28-Jährige Allgäuer
alle Duelle im Kampf Mann gegen Mann und
lässt im Finale dem Österreicher
raschler roter Kurs keine Chance siegt
erstmals in seiner Karriere gewinnt Gold
unglaublich ja ähm ich hab's selber
nicht erwartet und ähm unheimlich cool
zum ersten Mal seit 34 Jahren dominiert
ein deutscher wieder in einem WM
Einzelwettbewerb
das was von uns sehr sehr empfehlen
möchte ich Ihnen die Spezialausgabe des
auslandsjournals gleichem Anschluss
manche Pieper und ihre Kollegen sind in
Kiew und berichten von dort wie der
Krieg das Land verändert zerstört aber
auch geeint hat mit vielen tollen
Reportagen und Gesprächen und um 0:45
Uhr meldet sich dann Gundula Gause mit
unserem heutigen Update darin auch ein
Interview mit hessens Ministerpräsident
Rhein im Vorfeld des flüchtlingsgipfels
zu dem bundesinnenministerin Fräser für
morgen eingeladen hat auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend sicherlich haben Sie die
Bilder von den Überschwemmungen in
Neuseeland gesehen hier ein Bild von
gestern sieht sehen hier den Zyklon
Gabriel jetzt hat es sogar in der Nähe
von Wellington noch ein kleines Erdbeben
gegeben der Zyklon gabriel ist weiter
nach Südosten gezogen und damit
verlassen wir die andere Halbkugel und
kommen wieder zurück zu uns denn ich
möchte Ihnen ein weiteres Satellitenbild
zeigen und zwar von den Kanarischen
Inseln wenn Sahara Staub auf den
Atlantik hinausgetrieben wird und auf
den Kanarischen Inseln die sich trübt
heißt das Kalima dieser Sahara Stau wird
dann ins übliche Wetter Geschehen
einbezogen das sehen Sie hier auf diesem
Satellitenbild von gestern und manchmal
kommt von diesem Sahara Staub auch was
bei uns in Mitteleuropa an für Sie mal
orange schraffiert morgen werden sie das
als leichte lufttrübung vielleicht
erkennen können vor allen Dingen aber
kommen von Nordwesten einige Regenwolken
heran und das schon heute Nacht sonst
ist es wieder häufig neblig selten auch
mal klar und die Temperaturen sinken auf
plus fünf minus vier Grad die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen so
zwischen 7 und 15 Grad und morgen zieht
der Regen dann ein bisschen weiter nach
Südosten sehr viel Regen wird das nicht
sein am Vormittag regnet es zwischen der
Ostsee und Ostfriesland sonst geht es
nach Nebel viel Sonnenschein und da ist
mehr Wind gibt werden sich die
Nebelfelder auflösen nachmittags
erreicht der Regen dann auch die
Uckermark sehr stürmisch geht es dann an
den Küsten weiter und der Sonntag wird
kälter tschüss